il nous a violé il nous a détruit il a
détruit nos du ried jeune fille
notre vie de famille en disant nos
parents en nous disant que nos parents
dénoncer les actes de pédophilie dans
l'église des paroles rares avant les
années 2000
la faute à une institution qui a
longtemps su étouffer les polémiques
mais au fil du temps cette culture du
silence s'est brisé
[Musique]
les premières rares affaire médiatisée
en france remonte aux années 90 même si
leur retentissement était faible en
france les affaires ont du mal à sortir
de l'ombre
exemple en 1994 dans un collège privé en
bourgogne
quand la directrice a découvert des
photos à caractère pornographique
impliquant des élèves
elle a brisé le silence imposé par la
hiérarchie religieuse et a été licencié
mon devoir est de dénoncer
il doit être dénoncé l' affaire qui
brise la culture du silence
elle éclate en 1999 un abbé est jugé
pour viols et agressions sexuelles sur
quinze mineurs il écopera de 18 ans de
prison à l'issue de son procès mais
surtout son supérieur l'évêque était au
courant il fait alors l'objet d'une
plainte pour non dénonciation et mesure
qu aurait dû prendre lévesque s'est
d'abord en tant que citoyen avertir le
procureur de la république et faire en
sorte que les veys et que le curé ne
soit plus en relation avec des
adolescents sur le plan juridique la
question de la dénonciation est complexe
à l'époque d'un côté l'évêque qui reçoit
une confession est tenu au secret comme
un avocat ou un médecin
de l'autre la non dénonciation de crime
sur mineur est puni par la loi
dans cette affaire la justice des hommes
prend le pas sur celle de dieu l'évêque
est condamné à 3 mois de sursis en 2001
du jamais vu en france on ne pourra plus
se retrancher derrière le secret
professionnel pour s'abstenir de
dénoncer des faits graves de viols
commis sur des enfants mineurs
la sphère fait office de jurisprudence
en matière de pédophilie dans l'église
les scandales continuent d'éclater
depuis les années 2000 mais le nombre de
victimes et de prêtres impliqués reste
aujourd'hui encore inconnue
[Musique]